hey this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and I am going
to play through candy crush soda level
one twenty eight and talk about some of
the important things I do in this
commentary so if you look around
the chocolates all trapped in the
beginning so it can't grow outward they
can add extra layers on it like it did
there on the right but until the honey
is gone I can't really spread any
further than where it's at so it's real
important or one of the things I try to
do is not break out more than one side
at once the bottom usually opens up but
I don't really want the left and right
sides open at the same time one of the
things that makes this level so hard is
that it's really small inside here and
there's several colors involved so it's
hard enough to set up matches at you
know in the first place
so what I want to do is like how I did
here like I picked one side that I could
actually get through the honey on the
right side and now I'm gonna try to stay
over here and work on this as much as I
can when all else fails I'll hit the
chocolate at the bottom so that it
doesn't grow anywhere on the board and
we're gonna look to make um obviously
color bomb combos and color cane combos
but one thing that can be really helpful
here is striped Plus fish because it
could hit the whole row at once if it
goes the right way
so you know I'm playing pretty quickly
here because if you know if you look
there's really not a whole lot of
options but just sort of pay attention
to how I'll hit the hit the top of the
bottom everyone smile when I can but
mostly I'm just trying to work my way
over and clear out the whole right side
before I open up the left side and it's
sometimes what will happen is you'll get
stucked on the way but here's a chance
to use a striped plus a fish so we'll do
that I think the purple one's better
because that leaves the green and the
red next to each other you know now we
got to be careful because the chocolate
can grow everywhere
and as you can tell it's white chocolate
so it grows fast
I missed the color bomb up there I saw
as it was falling it's really not that
bad I was planning on getting notes -
you wrapped candies together like I did
and you can see that cleared out a lot
and made some really good cascade which
starts to work once the board's open so
no this is this is where you really need
to start paying attention we can make
this orange wrapped but it's not really
gonna be near anything you can make the
striped here I think that's better
and then it'll make that and now if we
slide the strap the striped up it should
get most of them and then we get the
other one in the Cascade so there you go
that's how it works
um definitely an annoying level it used
to be a lot worse oh it used to have
less moves when it first came out I
actually played it for hours and then
ended up using my lollipop to get past
it then went back and beat it without
visitors later so you know it's
definitely frustrating a lot of space
and the chocolate will grow fast so just
try to work on one part open it up try
to make your stripe plus fish and if you
get lucky I didn't there but if you get
lucky you try to make a color bomb or
coloring candy combo all right please
like this video share it with your
friends make sure you subscribe to our
channel we're the only channel that
makes these kind of commentary videos
for you and we make new ones all the
time so hope it helps Thanks